oh hello there
you may be wondering why the pink suit
so the world can see that I have a big
ol heart on that's heart with the T for
my new obsession pink the color not the
pop singer personally I'm more of a
saline kind of guy
pink is hide like a beautiful ribbon to
a cause very close to me cancer so
amazed and I are joining together scare
up some serious cash for [ __ ] cancer I'm
gonna donate the very suit off my back
while giving you a chance to own some mu
B marketing memorabilia what do you do
from there is limited only by your
imagination will you add it to your
weekly wardrobe rotation doesn't become
a colorful addition to your S&M dungeon
oh you simply nail it to a post in order
to scare away birds children and the
elderly visit the website below to get
all the details this is one fight where
everyone can be a hero no superpowers
capes or lame CG costumes needed just
your money seriously we need that these
suits aren't cheap
ed to amaze calm Ford / Deadpool and
together let's f cancer.com
hey everybody they drop some new
Deadpool last night because they
premiered the Deadpool movie on FX
networks right before they dropped
Legion episode 1 so obviously this is
like a funny promo and then trying to
raise money for cancer awareness if
you've watched any of the air / shows
you might know that Stephen Amell has
been doing the f cancer campaign for
like the last four years or so but they
just obviously use this Deadpool room
that they're using for all the promos
with all these weird Easter eggs lying
around and if you guys didn't know there
actually is a pink Deadpool costume in
the comics but it's not worn by Deadpool
it's worn by gwenpool
and it's a little bit different from
this this is really just a pink colored
version of his Deadpool costume that
they're auctioning off so like if you
win this raffle that they're doing as
part of this you actually get to keep
the real-life costume if you remember he
actually loaned the real-life Deadpool
costume that he kept after the movie to
Taylor Swift for Halloween the you that
the movie came out
you paint around the frame here there's
a lot of really obvious jokes like the
coffee mug just has boobs drawn all over
it the pillow just reads feminists the
unicorn he's stroking obviously
reference to the unicorn from the
credits sequence in the first movie he's
got a pink sprinkles Simpsons donut on
the table the pink flamingos not exactly
sure what that's a reference to this is
not like a pink paraphernalia all around
just to remind you about the cancer the
cancer montage from the first film
probably one of the best scenes of the
movie this is actually the deleted scene
of them just going back in fourth I'm
gonna want to move our relationship
completely to text and phone calls no
FaceTime no time around that face your
head looks like some sort of crystal
that you would see it a two bit psychic
can't touch it look like Shrek took a
[ __ ] on your neck look like somebody
turn your face inside out and then just
left it like that but then you got in a
house fire God you look like a house
fire was in another house fire wait you
look like a trash can full of [ __ ] was
placed on your shoulders and then you
were in a train fire they went up
deleting this just because they went too
long like they were ad-libbing a bunch
of different versions of the scenes so
they tried to go with the best version
of it
they used the idea of the cancer heavily
to market that first film I don't expect
it to be a big deal during the second
film because he can either have the
pretty phase or he can have the healing
factor the way they sort of glossed over
that technicality is by saying that
there would be side effects to
activating his new power like they just
had to torture him till he had some
biological response that would
automatically just turn on his X gene
well we'd have to keep on hunting in new
in different ways each more painful than
the last
[Music]
do you find any mutant the real reason
his face looks like that is is because
his healing factor brings him back to a
baseline is just that the baseline is
cancer face the X gene didn't activate
till after his cancer had done really
bad even he got his powers before all
this happened obviously it'd be a
non-issue he still look exactly like
Ryan Reynolds walking around in a suit
if you're not a big comic book reader
though there have been a couple times in
the comics when he has gotten his
pretty-looking Wade Wilson face back
there was volume 1 number 57 when he
rejoined the Weapon X program and then I
think even earlier back during volume 1
he went up against Loki spoiler alert do
not mess with Loki because he will
totally screw with you he makes a
Deadpool look like Tom Cruise only they
spelled a th om Tom Cruise I guess to
avoid lawsuits because this is back
before Deadpool was such a huge thing
Tom Cruise would be honored to be
parodied by Deadpool now but back then
it was actually a much bigger deal the
some of you may be more familiar with
the more recent mustache Deadpool from
the Secret Wars run a couple years ago
where he got his face back just briefly
but that was because time/space had been
altered so usually they are pretty good
about obeying the rules of his powers
like he can either have the healing
factor or he can have the pretty face
that's the basic rule obviously Deadpool
is a hero at the end of the day so he's
gonna use his powers to help people even
though he's gonna sass everyone and tell
jokes the whole time star in your own
horror films because you look like
Freddy Krueger face-fucked a
topographical map of Utah here's what
I'm actually gonna do I'm gonna work
through his crew until somebody gives up
francis force him to fix this then put a
bullet in his skull and [ __ ] the brain
hole i don't want to see that or think
of it again but the douchebag does think
you're dead right yeah that's good you
should keep it that way
what like wear a mask yes a very thick
mask all the time i am sorry you're
haunting your face is the stuff of
nightmares like a testicle of teeth you
will die alone if i mean if you could
die the way they're using this room is
just like they used that room for the
other deadpool movie like it was almost
the same two sets for all the IDs that
he would do like he would either tee up
some clip then they would play it or he
would
just do a lot of jokes in the stand-up
routine like they debuted clips on a
bunch of different shows there was even
a clip on The Bachelor
because they think on a practical level
they just wanted to get everybody to go
see the movie and for the most part when
he was still just a comic book character
just a videogame character his audience
was mostly male so they were just trying
to broaden his appeal hello you're
probably thinking my boyfriend said this
was a superhero movie surprise this is
actually lucky you a love story
when your worst enemy is after your best
girl it's time to be a superhero but now
that everybody is on board we'll see
what they end up doing with the
character but what's gonna happen is is
because the infinity war press tour is
officially starting now you may have
seen that funny fan ode demands your
silence car that the Bruce's were
revealing even Tom Holland was like oh
this letter is totally addressed to me
please don't spoil infinity war before
Tom Holland and Mark Ruffalo have a
chance to the Deadpool version of that
when they go on their press tour won't
start for a couple more weeks but you're
gonna start seeing a whole bunch of
funny stuff like this posting for both
infinity war and Deadpool 2 so if you
are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything
let me know if there are any specific
comic-book Deadpool videos that you want
me to do for Deadpool or infinity war 2
the Marvel stuff is a little more
self-explanatory we haven't quite got to
full Deadpool season yet and everybody's
still a little heartbroken at the
thought that we're not gonna get a
really cool animated Deadpool show but
no worries
what'll happen next is is I'll post my
legion episode 1 video that should be up
later today in a couple hours I have to
spend some time with family so we'll see
how fast I can get that done but click
here to rewatch the footage from that
cancelled show and click here for
brand-new infinity war
[Music]